long long time ago
I can still remember when the jump cut
was all the rage
and I know if I could get it right that
those friendly editors just my main
feature me up on the front
but now that might be in the past to be
the demon corporate master that dream
might now be dead
despite the ads by my head and as hard
as YouTube tries to offer excuses and
official wise will finally truth within
lies the day
the tubes die
oh why am I even surprised maybe YouTube
can be and avoid its demise but it comes
at the cost of the little
is then I think
my goodbyes
I think that I might say my goodbyes
did you do the fatback's finger batiste
and they go
Lasher had fun
if you remember your first comment at
how
thus the characters man
laughs the capture goes
I'll miss it all when I'm stuck behind
this content wall baby won't spell
curtains I'll still have my
subscriptions
yeah I won't give jungle smashing
forget all your budget job well I hope
they won't be out of luck of the day you
Tuesday
I started vlogging while
why am I even surprised maybe YouTube
Gaby and about its demise but if it
comes at the cost of the little guys
then I think that I might say my
goodbyes
I think that I let's say my goodbyes
everybody with me one time surprised
maybe
[Music]
okay
my eyes
[Music]
that was hilariously difficult first I
had to take this to my camera so that I
could remember all the chords so that's
why I didn't realize there was a big
reflection in my eyeball the whole time
because I couldn't see myself on my
monitor and second I kept doing this I
even surprised maybe made or something
later now he's just a small fry let's go
boys mistake right yes there can be too
many parodies for one song sorry to
contribute to that wardrobe change
thank you go to all the people in my
little youtube chorus Allen fall of
autumn distro of course while writing
most of that song but most of all thanks
to all of you because YouTube is not
what Google does YouTube is what we do
and what you're doing down there I'm
sure you know what I mean by down there
so thank you for doing what we do
because it's freaking awesome and I got
a haircut what do you think